[Music]
the periodic table is more than just a
list of the elements it's a scientific
roadmap it's also one of the most
important tools for scientists in a wide
range of fields from chemistry to
quantum mechanics
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream in
this episode of perspectives three
scientists discuss how the periodic
table came to be and some interesting
ways it can be used to predict how the
world works
we begin now with a brief look at the
periodic table years before it took its
familiar shape enjoy
[Music]
the periodic table is much more than
just a reference tool for chemists
it's also a history book that tells a
history of discoveries as well as what
we've made of those discoveries
if you look closely at the table's
evolution over the past 150 years
you'll find that the names symbols
positions of elements and even the shape
of the table itself have all changed in
various ways
and each of these updates captures a
story of discovery scientific
achievement
human ambition and sometimes even global
politics
this is why the periodic table is one of
the most iconic images in all of science
it is so much more than just a listing
of all 118 known elements
it's a table of contents for the rich
and much larger story of our constantly
evolving understanding of matter by 1860
about 60 chemical elements were known
enough for scientists to start
organizing them
the first person to recognize that there
was a repetition in the properties of
the elements was the french geologist
alexandre de chanchois
unfortunately deshawn courtois used a
lot of geology terminology and his
contributions were missed by the chemist
at the time
in 1864 english chemist john newlands
grouped the known elements into 11
groups and
noting that the weights differed by
multiples of 8 proposed a law of octaves
based on an analogy to musical scales
this wasn't appreciated very much by his
contemporary colleagues though and it
wasn't until over 60 years later
that a variation of his law of octaves
gained some experimental support
in 1864 german chemist julius lothar
meyer published a chart of elements but
it included less than half of the known
elements and so has been found wanting
by science historians no the big
breakthrough came in 1869 when russian
chemist dmitry mendeleev published a
chart of the elements that was the first
version of the modern periodic table
but mendeleev did something that no one
else did
he left gaps in his chart if an element
didn't fit the correct progression of
chemical properties
his excuse
perhaps these elements hadn't been
discovered yet
and based on the properties of other
elements around them
mendeleev predicted some of the chemical
and physical properties of these missing
elements
a bold move but mendeleev was right
six years later the element's gallium
was discovered and it had almost exactly
the same properties that mendeleev
predicted
not long after that a new element
scandium and another germanium were
discovered and their properties agreed
very well with mendeleev's predictions
for these reasons mendeleev is more
generally considered the inventor of the
periodic table rather than meijer
the secret to the ability of mendeleev's
table to group elements with similar
properties so long ago is that those
properties he used atomic mass
and valence
are closely related to certain features
of atomic structure
specifically atomic number and the
structure of the electron cloud that
drive the organization of the table
today
this graphical organization of the
elements based on their fundamental
structure has stunning power to bring
together similar elements
precious metals like silver platinum and
gold cluster in one region
essential nutrients sodium potassium and
calcium cluster together
sharing the first period are hydrogen
and helium which are the primary players
in the nuclear reactions that power our
sun
the iron and nickel that make up most of
our planet's core are close neighbors
even the elements most essential to life
carbon nitrogen oxygen phosphorus and
sulfur cluster together in their own
tidy group of non-metals near the top
right corner
and there's so much more
each element's place on the table is
determined by its atomic structure and
an atom's structure influences its
properties
the table systematic organization of
elements in terms of their atoms offers
to share tremendous insights when it
comes to the abundance distribution and
properties of the elements and compounds
in the world around us
now here's an interesting fact
almost all chemistry happens because of
valence electrons
when you think about it it makes sense
the valence electrons are farthest away
from the nucleus
so they're the inner electrons that can
interact with other atoms almost all
chemistry is valence electrons in the
first two columns of the table the
valence electrons are always going to be
s subshells
we call the first two columns the s
block of the periodic table
on the right side
the six columns that are the valence
electrons going into p subshells we
therefore call this the p block of the
periodic table
similarly we have the d block
and the f block is that section that we
usually break away and place underneath
the rest of the blocks
these labels emphasize our understanding
of the subshell nature for the table
shape okay now that we're in a safe
place where we can observe these
reactions or these properties of alkali
metals i've secured three of them for us
to look at i have lithium metal which is
from the second row of the periodic
table
i have sodium metal which is from the
third row and potassium metal which
comes from the fourth row of the
periodic table now each one has just one
valence electron that it's going to lose
in a reaction with water to form
hydrogen gas which is flammable what's
called a hydroxide ion which we're going
to detect using a very special compound
called an indicator essentially it's
going to turn red when these hydroxide
ions form in solution but of course what
we're really out to observe is the
formation of the ions of these three
that take place during the reaction and
even more specifically just how
vigorously these reactions take place
because we've already predicted based
upon the periodic table zone structure
that we should see a trend in exactly
how rapidly and violently these
reactions take place so let's get
started with lithium
and you can see the solution is
beginning to turn reddish an indication
that we're making hydroxide
and there's also obviously a gas forming
and that's hydrogen gas except for
vessing
but also you'll notice by the end of the
reaction that that lithium chunk will be
gone because it's no longer lithium
metal it's now lithium one ions
dissolved into solution
here we go
now here you can see that the reaction
is going more vigorously in fact so
vigorously that the heat it generates
has melted the sodium metal and it's
actually a little ball of sodium metal
now that's dancing around on the surface
of the water
oh there we go and that little bit of
hydrogen gas ignited right at the end
evidence that we are in fact conducting
the reaction that we believe we are
okay here is potassium
all right
now regardless of what you may have
thought of the sodium and lithium
reactions i think we can all agree that
this reaction was far more violent same
exact reaction the only difference was
that our alkali metals came from
different rows of the periodic table a
periodic trend
the d block region of the table is also
sometimes casually referred to as the
transition metals so how did that name
come about
well in 1919 irving langmuir published
the famous paper entitled the
arrangement of electrons in atoms and
molecules
and in his paper langmuir asserted that
each principal energy level must feel
completely before the next is populated
but in 1921 english chemist charles
berry published a paper challenging
langmuir's postulate
he proposed that certain properties of
elements in what he called the long
periods could be better explained if
elements did indeed start to place
electrons in a higher energy level
then
transition back into filling an interior
shell with even more electrons
yuri suggested that this was exactly
what was happening in elements from
scandium to zinc and he was right
those elements have switched to a
transitional process of filling an
interior energy level with electrons
before getting back to filling their
outer shell
some of my favorite colors are produced
by transition metals
i'll never forget the day in chemistry
class that we did an experiment with the
different oxidation states of cobalt and
in the same test tube we produced
several different oxidation states that
ranged in color from pink to purple to
blue
it was beautiful
the transition metals are in the very
middle of the periodic table and when we
count the number of electrons that these
metals have we see that they have
partially filled d shells
if you have a hunk of pure metal like
silver or copper or gold it usually
looks shiny because of all of the
metallic electrons but when you take a
transition metal and put it inside of an
insulating chemical compound one that's
not shiny or metallic the colors that we
see in this case are dominated by those
d shell electrons in the transition
metal ion
and its transitions within these d
shells that cause the beautiful colors
they're responsible for the many
different colors of soda lime glass
gems and minerals and pigments that get
used in a variety of applications
including paint
the exact color that's produced will
depend on exactly which visible colors
are absorbed by the pigment
that's mostly going to depend on which
transition metal is used and what its
oxidation state is that is how many
electrons the metal has given up to the
surrounding compound that it's in
let's look at a specific example to see
how this goes
corundum is a mineral made of aluminum
and oxygen
its chemical composition is aluminum two
oxygen three
pure corundum is colorless
but if you take colorless corundum and
add a little bit of the transition metal
chromium to the mix then you get a
lovely red ruby
in a ruby crystal roughly every 200th
aluminum atom has been replaced with a
chromium atom
it's the quantum transitions that the
electrons make within the chromium ions
that give ruby its beautiful red color
the bottom line is that chromium in this
context ends up having three electrons
in its d shell
they can then have transitions among
those d levels that are the right energy
to pull some of the photons out of our
visible range
one of those transitions happens at 556
nanometers which is yellow that's
slightly on the greener side the other
transition that's in the visible range
happens at 400 nanometers which is
violet
so imagine now white light shining on
this ruby crystal
those chromium ions are going to take
away the greenish yellow light and
they're going to take away the violet
light through absorption which causes
transitions of their d shell electrons
that means that what gets reflected back
to our eyes and also what transmits
through the crystal is just whatever
light is left and doesn't get absorbed
that's mostly going to be red light
along with just a little bit of blue
so this is responsible for the overall
brilliant red color of the ruby
although many transition elements are
indeed capable of making beautiful
colored compounds when combined with
other elements molybdenum and its
neighbors on the table are probably best
known for their uses as pure metals or
alloys in engineering and construction
molybdenum is one of the hardest metals
with one of the highest known melting
points
the strange fact that it was named using
a greek word for lead is because one of
its common compounds molybdenum sulfide
was known to have soft properties that
resembled actual lead
the strong trend of increasing melting
points and density is clear as we
descend from chromium to molybdenum to
tungsten
the latter two are well known for their
durability and use in high temperature
applications like lighting where
tungsten filaments can literally be
heated to white hot temperatures and
still remain a solid
but tungsten's position in the sixth
period also gives it awesome density at
19 grams per cubic centimeter it rivals
that of uranium
now thankfully tungsten has two stable
isotopes this means that tungsten can be
used for example to forge conventional
military munition projectiles with
density and hardness of so-called
depleted uranium but without the
radiological toxicological and
environmental challenges that depleted
uranium poses
many modern armor-piercing munitions are
made partially or even completely of
tungsten
now whether you need a material with
high density and heat resistance
light weight and durability or even a
splash of color
the early transition metals with their
allocation of available the subshell
electrons are just the ticket
so does the periodic table have any
final upper limit
from a nucleus perspective it's hard to
say but the physicist richard feynman is
said to have predicted that the story of
the periodic table might end at element
137
not because of unstable nuclei but
because calculations predict that
electrons orbiting such a nucleus would
have to exceed the speed of light just
to stay in orbit
more recent estimates that take
relativistic effects into account has
suggested there may be room to fill in a
throw that goes all the way to element
172.
now the truth is
we really don't know where the limit is
which is one of the great things about
the practice of science if you've asked
me
a final question is
why keep going
why spend many thousands or even
millions of dollars on the quest to make
a single atom of a completely alien
substance
well why indeed
the practical response to this question
is always to cite the island of
stability and the possibility that
someday humanity will make a stable
super-heavy element with all new
properties for us to study and exploit
for our benefit
but another compelling reason is the
same that any scientist in any field
would offer
because we don't know what we don't know
and wouldn't it be a shame to miss out
on a world-changing discovery just
because we lacked the understanding to
predict that it'd be there
and it makes sense to keep going
precisely because of how much knowledge
is already embodied in the periodic
table
an awesome tool to guide us on our
exploration of matter and the universe
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here